Salut ! Dans une précédente vidéo,
je vous avais parlé des micro-expressions.
Découverts dans les années 70 par Paul Ekman,
son travail a montré que
l'ensemble de l'humanité possédait à peu près
les mêmes micro-expressions,
les même émotions sur son visage, visibles
de manière très rapide, très courte,
suite au ressenti d'une émotion particulière.
Le problème, c'est que ces expressions sincères ne
durent qu'un quart de seconde.
En moyenne.
Il est donc compliqué de les détecter,
et donc de les analyser.
Suite à vos nombreux commentaires pour que je rentre
plus dans le détail, j'ai donc décidé de créer
cette semaine de la micro-expression.
Avec aucun rapport avec Halloween. Je suis
le seul mec sur YouTube qui n'a pas du tout
prévu un truc pour Halloween.
C'est pas très grave.
Aujourd'hui, jusqu'à dimanche, nous analyserons
ensemble chacune des micro-expressions…
des sept micro-expressions majeures, et nous verrons
comment les détecter et comment les analyser.
Tous les jours, je vous donnerai également
des conseils supplémentaires sur, on va dire,
les généralités des micro-expressions.
J'espère que cette idée vous plaira ;
n'oubliez pas liker, de partager ces vidéos
si elle vous plaisent.
Et c'est parti pour la première d'entre elles, avec la colère.
La colère est la base des émotions d'agressivité,
qui peut même aller jusqu'à la rage.
La rage !
La chose à savoir, c'est qu'elle peut
surgir n'importe quand
au cours d'une conversation. Par exemple, parce que
vous faites référence à
quelqu'un qui a fait un sale coup à la personne
qui est en face de vous,
à qui vous discuter. Mais vous, vous savez pas
que la personne, elle a fait un sale coup
à cette personne. Donc l'autre personne,
celle à qui vous parler…
Suivez, un petit peu !
… va chercher à contenir un petit peu sa colère,
mais vous aller pouvoir la voir passer.
Les signes majeurs sont les sourcils qui
froncent, en tout cas l'intérieur des sourcils
qui froncent pour descendre vers le nez, comme ça,
un petit peu. Ouh, je suis en colère !
Également, le pincement des lèvres.
Là, je pince pas très, très
bien, dans l'exemple, mais les lèvres qui se pincent
un petit peu. Ne vous
attendez pas à voir les muscles forcer à leur maximum,
parce que là ça deviendrait
une expression ; c'est une micro-expression, donc
c'est un léger mouvement.
C'est bref, c'est furtif.
Mais le réel indicateur à prendre en compte,
sans perdre de vue
les autres, c'est la dilatation des narines.
[Respire bruyamment]
La vrai colère, celle qui est profonde,
elle passe toujours par ce signal-là.
Une autre des caractéristiques de la colère,
c'est qu'en général, quand on est
en colère, le regard reste fixe.
Là, je suis en colère…
et je te regarde… fixement…
Alors oui, bien sûr, c'est compliqué de les détecter.
Sauf si vous filmez, que vous
pouvez vous repasser les bandes au ralenti.
Mais vous pouvez, lors d'une conversation,
regarder de manière passive et globale
l'intégralité de la personne qui
est en face de vous. Quand vous lui parlez,
concentrez-vous sur un ensemble,
essayez d'être… euh… Jean-Claude van Damme dirait :
« Essayez d'être aware.»
Mais c'est presque ça. Vous devez avoir
une pleine conscience du visage qui est
en face de vous, pour être vraiment sensible
au moindre changement d'expression.
Au cours de cette semaine, je vais vous proposer
de vous concentrer sur des
points-clefs, et de les regarder du coin de l'oeil,
comme on dit. Comme ça, quand ils
vont se modifier, bouger, sur les un quart de seconde
que dure une micro-expression,
vous y serez plus sensible.
Avant d'analyser une micro-expression,
il faut pouvoir la détecter !
C'est là tout le but de ces vidéos.
Pour commencer, ayez conscience sur le visage
de l'autre, à la personne à qui vous parlez,
de ses lèvres, de ses sourcils intérieurs – c'est-à-dire au
niveau du nez – ainsi que de ses narines.
En clair, prenez conscience de cet axe-là.
Juste cet axe-là.
Donc, les lèvres ici, vous les verrez si elles
se pincent à ce niveau-là aussi ;
les narines ; et les sourcils intérieurs, leurs
mouvements. Vous savez quoi regarder.
Si vous voulez lire une partie du travail de Paul Ekman,
je vous recommande vivement
le livre «Je sais que vous mentez», que je vous met en
lien dans la description.
Je vous met aussi dans la description une
nouvelle playlist, que je vais
créer cette semaine, qui va reprendre
l'intégralité des vidéos que j'ai
faites sur les micro-expressions et
celles de cette semaine,
ce sera plus simple pour vous,
pour vous y retrouver.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo,
n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner au Mental Vlog, ici ou ici.
Parce que c'est une vidéo par jour
depuis le premier janvier,
donc rendez-vous demain à 17 heures. Ciao.
(Générique de fin)